bonjour à tous je vais écouter je vois
que la présence d'un ministre
même un jeudi maintenant
permet
la présence de nombreux de nos membres
de la de cette mission d'information
bien bienvenue à tous alors mes chers
collègues nous poursuivons les travaux
de notre émission d'information sur le
développement d'une filière de
biocarburant
carburant synthétique durable et
hydrogène vert en accueillant ce matin
monsieur Marc fenault notre ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire
alors je voulais d'abord excuser le
président de vinasse qui avait
aujourd'hui des obligations dans son
département notamment par rapport à un
tunnel de Turin
et je peux comprendre qu'il était
nécessaire pour lui d'y être présent
je rappelle que cette réunion est captée
elle est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat sur lequel elle pourra
ensuite être consultée en vidéo et à la
demande de qui le souhaitera monsieur le
ministre notre mission d'information
comprend des membres issus de
différentes commissions qui représentent
l'ensemble des groupes politiques du
Sénat
le développement des filières
biocarburant le carburant synthétique
durable et d'hydrogène vert représente
un enjeu important pour permettre à la
France et à l'Union européenne
d'atteindre l'objectif de neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050 mais aussi
également pour notre souveraineté et la
compétitivité de notre entreprise
économique
la France a développé une politique
ambitieuse en matière de biocarburant
qui a eu des effets significatifs tant
en termes de production que
d'incorporation de biodiesel ou de
bioéthanol dans les carburants
nous avons constaté lors de nos
auditions que ces orientations se
trouvent aujourd'hui contestés ou
interrogé par la Cour des comptes comme
par des organisations non
gouvernementales par exemple
l'organisation de Transport et
Environnement nous voyons bien également
que contrairement à ce qui pratique ce
qui pratique qui est pratiquée aux
États-Unis la première génération de
biocarburant qui est mature sur le plan
industriel n'aurait plus le vent en
poupe au niveau de l'Union européenne
notamment lorsqu'il s'agit d'envisager
des voies de décarbonation pour le
transport maritime et pour le transport
aérien
pourtant de grandes industries ont
estimé devant la mission que la deuxième
génération de biocarburant n'est pas
mature sur le plan industriel et ont
pointé plusieurs difficultés notamment
de disponibilités de collecte de la
biomasse mais a-t-on aujourd'hui une
stratégie claire de valorisation de la
biomasse à des fins énergétiques et de
production du carburant durable
il est donc essentiel que nous puissions
avoir analyse de ces enjeux et qui ne
sont pas minces bien évidemment pour le
monde agricole notre rapporteur monsieur
Vincent capocanella vous a adressé un
questionnaire qui peut vous servir de
guide mais vous pouvez bien sûr et
naturellement introduire vos votre
propre vos propos comme vous l'entendez
bien évidemment je sais que votre temps
est compté et que nous avons chers
collègues une heure de passer avec notre
ministre pour avoir les réponses à
toutes les questions que nous lui
poserons après sa présentation voilà je
vous passe la parole de Monsieur le
Ministre
merci Monsieur le vice-président
monsieur vous m'entendez oui
monsieur le vice-président monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs merci de m'accueillir ce matin
au Sénat
une question qu'on traite pas toujours
assez souvent je trouve cette question
des biocarburants et l'usage de la
biomasse je pense qu'on va être appelé
en parler à plusieurs reprises ce qui a
bien des sujets qui vont naître dans les
mois les années qui viennent notamment
avec l'accélération et des objectifs sur
des carbonations puis neutralité carbone
qui remettent au cœur des enjeux cette
question là donc merci de m'accueillir
je voudrais ça me permet au travers
cette invitation de de m'exprimer
d'échanger avec vous sur les sujets des
biocarburants qui sont des sujets
importants comme ça a été dit par les
sénateurs Kuiper qui relève de plusieurs
dimensions des dimensions agricoles des
dimensions énergétiques des dimensions
industrielles des dimensions de mobilité
des dimensions environnementales des
dimensions de lutte contre changement
climatique c'est dire si c'est assez
multi fonctionnel il y a effectivement
un questionnaire alors je vais essayer
on vous l'enverra
précisément
étayer mais je vais essayer de répondre
à un certain nombre de questions qui se
posent sur cette question là d'abord
dire que le moment qu'on traverse est un
moment où on voit bien que les
agriculteurs je mets aussi les
forestiers pour d'autres raisons mais
des agriculteurs mais étant ministre
aussi des forêts je dis au passage sur
des acteurs incontournables de la
transition
énergétique et de la décarbonation pour
une raison simple c'est que c'est au
travers de leurs activités que ce
produit l'élément essentiel que nous
connaissons c'est à dire la biomasse
c'est des belles ressources à partir de
la photosynthèse qui peuvent être
valorisants produits biosourcés et
énergies renouvelables le rôle de
l'agriculture et de la sylviculture dans
ce domaine et aussi central pour passer
d'une économie fondée sur des ressources
fossiles à une économie durable
compétitive et sur du carbone qui soit
du carbone renouvelable et donc c'est
une partie de la stratégie que nous
avons est une stratégie qui est basée
là-dessus la filière française de
biocarburant de première génération
contribue de dans ce cadre-là depuis
2005 ça fait bientôt 20 ans à la
décarbonation en particulier du secteur
des transports ces débouchés non
alimentaires de production agricole
s'inscrivent en France en
complémentarité et synergies avec les
débouchés alimentaires au travers de nos
filières intégrées et c'est d'ailleurs
tout l'intérêt me semble-t-il du modèle
français qui s'est construite dès le
début quasiment sur cette question
énergétique
le bilan environnemental des biocarbures
en première génération est souvent
ramené par mon sens un peu trop souvent
ramené à une question de concurrence
avec d'autres usages évidemment en
particulier l'alimentation c'est un
débat ancien initié dans les années 2000
lors de l'émergence de la filière vous
vous en souvenez et sans doute pierre
plus que d'autres encore la
réglementation européenne ayant
finalement plafonné la contribution des
biocarburants de première génération dès
la directive du 9 septembre 2015 qui
prévoit que leur part d'énergie ne doit
pas être supérieure à 7% de la
consommation finale d'énergie dans les
transports
France agrimaire dans le cadre de sa
veille économique et de ses missions un
produit des estimations des surfaces
nettes correspondant aux surfaces
effectivement consacrée aux cultures
destinées au bulcarburant de première
génération déduction faite de la surface
théorique nécessaire à la production des
coproduits issus des biocarburants et
destinés à l'alimentation animale
puisque c'est bien aussi le schéma dans
lequel on se situe la part de SASU net
allouée donc au biocarburant en France
en 2021
était ainsi de 0,7% pour la filière
bioéthanol
et de 2,5% pour la filière biodésale
ces chiffres montrent de permettre
peut-être aussi de rationaliser le débat
et de le mettre au niveau d'enjeux qui
est le sien pas au dessus
pas au dessus surtout pas en dessous
évidemment mais surtout pas au dessus de
ce que c'est et donc c'est de mettre
ramener à son juste au niveau ce débat
qui a toujours été récurrent sur cette
filière en ce qui concerne les atteintes
à la biodiversité qui sont parfois des
critiques qu'on se sont formulées la
Commission européenne a mené un travail
dans le cadre de son règlement délégué
le mars 2019 qui a permis d'identifier
la palme et dans un moindre mesure le
soja comme source de risque élevé de
changement d'affectation des sols en
cohérence avec sa stratégie nationale de
lutte contre la déforestation importée
la France a d'abord exclu l'île de palme
de l'incitation fiscale et l'huile de
soja à partir du 1er janvier 2022 la
France a donc pris les mesures qui
s'imposaient et qui étaient demandées je
crois dans le sens de la préservation
des terres bénéficiants d'un stock
important de carbone il est également
important de rappeler que chaque lot de
carburant incorporé ou importé sur le
territoire français doit être déclaré au
sein d'une déclaration de durabilité
c'est comme ça qu'elle s'appelle
transmise mensuellement par les
opérateurs de la direction de l'énergie
et du climat conformément à la directive
sur les énergies renouvelables dites
directives Red et ces textes
d'application cette déclaration permet
de contrôler que chaque biocarburant mis
à la consommation sur le territoire
français respectent des critères de
durabilité liés aux terres et à
l'obligation de réduction de 50 à 60 %
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
par rapport au carburant fossiles par
ailleurs lorsque la question des
biocarbures conventionnels est abordée
il convient de tenir compte des
externalités positives induite notamment
par les coproduits les pulpes les
drêches les tourteaux et en termes de
souveraineté protéique pour
l'alimentation animale loin d'être un
concurrent aux cultures alimentaires la
culture de biocarburant n’est un
complément dont bien des cas ces
cultures favorisent la production de
matières destinées à l'alimentation
animale libérant ainsi des surfaces de
culture céréalières qui peuvent donc
être
directement en première intention à
l'alimentation humaine la tête de
rotation que constitue le causa
représente également un avantage
agronomique que je ne vais pas décrire
devant un certain nombre de gens qui
connaissent mieux que moi aux pratiques
mieux que moi ce sujet et donc c'est un
avantage agronomique évidemment
indéniable à la vérité rien de nouveau
dans ce que je viens de dire et rien que
qu'il soit pas déjà sur la table tout ça
là avait été exposé par le Sénat par
vous monsieur le sénateur Kuyper s'il y
a déjà un certain temps dans le rapport
d'information de 2019 et vous êtes
investi depuis longtemps sur ce qui a
par contre changé depuis 2019
c'est la guerre en Ukraine et ses
conséquences qui ont bouleversé les
circuits d'approvisionnement des
produits d'énergétiques fossiles et
rappeler la nécessité d'être plus encore
qu'aujourd'hui ou qu'hier souverain en
termes d'énergie
rappelant aussi notre trop forte
dépendance
et nous de la trop forte dépendance de
nos modes de vie de nos économies aux
énergies fossiles importées dans ce cas
alors qu'il est nécessaire de
reconquérir notre souveraineté
énergétique bénéficier de deux filières
structurées durables de production de
bruit au carburant avec des
infrastructures et des outils
industriels d'intégrer dans nos
territoires me paraît un atout
considérable des évolutions dans le mix
énergétique sont attendues dans les
années à venir les biocarburants de
première génération peuvent pleinement
contribuer à l'enjeu de d'accélération
du développement des énergies
renouvelables et décorbonation
l'ensemble des transports comme ils
l'ont fait depuis 20 ans considérant les
évolutions que je considère comme
structurelles envisagé pour la mobilité
légère avec l'électrification engagée du
parc automobile nous devons donc nous
continuer à nous appuyer sur ces
carburants de première génération et
notre filière française afin de réussir
la transition de la mobilité lourde
routière et non routière
nous pouvons aussi parler de la
possibilité du secteur agricole de
valoriser directement et assez
rapidement sans investissement trop
lourd c'est biocarburant pour décarboner
les engins agricoles c'est aussi un
enjeu 10 à 12%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
secteur agricole sont liés aux engins
agricoles donc c'est une part qui n'est
pas inintéressante et c'est une fin sur
laquelle on peut agir plus facilement
sans doute encore que je ne vois rien de
très facile dans ce que nous avons à
faire mais peut-être plus facilement que
dans d'autres dans d'autres domaines il
me semblait donc important de rappeler
ces éléments sur les biocarburants par
ailleurs en cohérence avec les objectifs
poursuivis au niveau européen pour la
décarbonation des transports il sera
nécessaire de mobiliser une part plus
importante de biocarburant de deuxième
génération un enjeu essentiel réside
aussi dans notre capacité à développer
une filière française de production de
biocarburant de deuxième génération plus
structurée encore cela pose à la fois
l'enjeu de la mobilisation de la matière
première bio sur C
correspondante mais aussi le
développement des technologies de
transformation et les process
d’industrialisation évidemment pour nous
prendre que l'exemple de l'aérien le
respect des objectifs de décarbonation
du secteur aérien nécessitera de
déterminer la part entre importation de
carburant durable et la production
nationale qu'avec au-delà des projets
déjà soutenus des incertitudes sur la
capacité à l'échelle industrielle pour
répondre au à terme aux besoins de
biocarburant avancés diffuel en France
la part entre if fuel et biocarburant
avancé dans la production nationale en
fonction des bouclages biomasse et
énergies qui sont les bouclages que nous
ont fait avec des transferts possibles
entre les secteurs aériens maritimes et
routiers c'est là qu'on peut avoir des
sujets d'interrogations l'équation est
donc complexe et c'est tout l'enjeu de
discussion que nous aurons à l'occasion
d'élaboration de la programmation
énergique climat de la France et pour
laquelle la concertation va s'échelonner
débuter et se poursuivre on va dire elle
a quand même commencé dans les
prochaines semaines il me semble qu'il
faut être très attentif je disais
particulièrement aux enjeux biomasse
d'abord parce qu'il y a un changement
d'échelle
la question des biocarburants est une
question pleine et entière de la
transition que nous devons être beaucoup
plus au coeur de cette question là
aujourd'hui qui est il me semble que
c'est un élément important deuxième
élément j'ai parlé de la guerre en
Ukraine comme un élément structurant de
modification deuxième élément
structurant de modification quand on
fait un appel de biomasse comme celui
parce que j'ai pas parlé pardon
excusez-moi j'ai un chat dans la gorge
[Musique]
j'ai pas parlé des autres
usages de la biomasse qui sont demandés
par un simple pour la construction et
donc là on a besoin de quand même bien
réfléchir à ce qui est pour la partie
agricole en tout cas la capacité à
continuer à produire de la biomasse à la
vérité on a plus que jamais besoin de
produire de la biomasse et donc ça pose
une autre question sous-jacente qui fait
partie de débats qu'on a eu il y a
quelques semaines ou quelques jours au
Sénat c'est comment on continue à
permettre à l'agriculture française de
produire de la biomasse première
attention l'agriculture c'est de la
produit de la biomasse avec des
destinations diverses et dès lors qu'on
a besoin d'usage et que la stratégie que
nous avons tant sur le question
forestière que sur les questions
agricoles sont des stratégies qui
viennent faire appel à la biomasse parce
que c'est quand même une des éléments
les meilleurs au-delà de changer des
trajectoires de consommation enfin quand
même pour décarboner un moment faut
faire appel à la Bible c'est donc on a
besoin aussi de penser notre système en
ce qui permet aux agriculteurs de
continuer à produire de l’ambiomate dans
des conditions qui soient des conditions
durant de rentabilité et donc les
secteurs agricoles et forestiers sont et
resteront
à mon avis plus que jamais des secteurs
avec des solutions notamment à travers
la production de biocarburant mais je le
disais à l'instant sur d'autres usages
la valorisation de la biomasse dans un
objectif énergétique est une nécessité
nécessité climatique et puis aussi c'est
une faut le dire ça a été pour la
première génération une une opportunité
économique avec de la création de la
valeur de valeur ajoutée la
diversification d'activité des créations
d'emplois pour le coup assez peu encore
que assez peu délocalisables et des
emplois qui sont présents dans les
territoires et donc c'est ça qu'il faut
les bio carburants font partie du mix
énergétique qui constituent le socle de
la programmation comme vous le savez
plus annuelle de l'énergie pour
atteindre l'objectif de neutralité
carbone en 2050 avec électricité
énergithermique biogaz issue de la
méthanisation hydrogène notamment la loi
d'accélération
a apporté une première pierre à
l'édifice en particulier en posant les
bases du développement de la
grivevoltase c'est un autre sujet mais
c'est aussi un élément complémentaire et
donc simplement dire pardon d'avoir été
peut-être un peu long mais ça permettait
de balayer un certain nombre de sujets
il me semble que on doit réfléchir à la
manière dont avec les agriculteurs avec
les filières avales on peut construire
des filières qui continuent plus que
jamais à se développer j'ajoute un
élément le dérèglement climatique va
faire évoluer parfois des bassins de
production
de même que tel ou telle évolution liée
à l'interdiction de tel ou telle produit
phytosanitaire il faut qu'on pense nos
systèmes aval avec ce que vont être les
bassins de production dans non pas 5 ans
mais 10 15 20 ans compte tenu des
évolutions climatiques on sait qu'il y a
des contraintes climatiques qui vont
s'exercer pour tout le monde mais qui
ont des impacts plus lourd dans certains
secteurs que dans d'autres d'un point de
vue d'un point de vue de ce qu'on peut
produire comme à seulement et donc il me
semble qu'on aura une réflexion à mener
là-dessus aussi voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire et je les ai essayé de
répondre à vos questions
merci Monsieur le Ministre première
réaction de ma part et je passerai la
parole de notre rapporteur
quand je vois aujourd'hui
la crise énergétique qui est quand même
là et le risque qui est le nôtre du
black-out d'approvisionnement
énergétique quand on pense notamment aux
tout électrique et je me pose la
question sur est-ce que le renouvelable
est bien au rendez-vous donc vous avez
émis un certain de bonnes intentions
après c'est les moyens
monsieur le rapporteur
merci Monsieur prudent merci beaucoup
d'avoir monsieur le ministre d'avoir
accepté l'invitation de de la mission
je vois le sens de la stabilité qui a
toujours été le vôtre et j'espère que
vous serez un précurseur parce que
membres du gouvernement n'ont pas encore
répondu à nos invitations c'est un signe
d'ouverture de votre part par rapport au
Sénat et aux travaux qui sont qui sont
les nôtres niés particulièrement
sensibles ça nous étonne pas c'est ce
que ça vaut votre
écoute du Parlement et vous l'avez
montré dans différentes fonctions
sur le propos liminaire que vous avez eu
je voudrais d'abord saluer le fait que
vous avez rappelé les garanties les
limites
dans la mise en oeuvre de la première
génération
et les externalités positives des
coproduits il y a de meilleur
spécialistes que moi là-dessus donc je
vais essayer d'être assez bref mais
j'ai entendu le propos qui est rappelé
que les bi ocarbures de première
génération
contribuent et peuvent contribuer à la
transition écologique et je voudrais
dire c'est un peu le hasard du
calendrier mais nous avons reçu
monsieur faniché le Président de la SNCF
voyageur je crois que c'était mardi qui
nous a dit que pour la partie des lignes
qui n'étaient pas électrifiées combien
ils comptaient sur les blocs carburants
et il se trouve que on a entendu hier le
représentant de d'Airbus et du
groupement des industriels aéronautique
et spatiaux qui nous ont dit aussi avec
son équipe combien la part de
biocarburant allait être dans un premier
temps avant de passer au wifioul un
élément de transition potentielle donc
il y a une attente sur ce point alors le
Président il a fait allusion dans son
propre polymère il y a quelques
critiques je crois que vous avez
partiellement répondu mais parce que on
a entendu le message qui est réaffirmé
les choses là-dessus
bon peut-être qu'on y reviendra là
dessus mais voilà
j'entends le message d'abord qui est
dire que cette première génération elle
tient si j'ose dire elle tient ses
promesses
il y a quand même quelques points qu'il
faudrait quand même qu'on précise
peut-être par rapport à aux critiques
entendues
sur la deuxième génération
j'ai compris que vous me disiez qu'il
fallait de l'industrialiser la structuré
et que ça posait quand même
effectivement la question au bout d'un
moment de changement d'échelle
alors on l'entend jusque je viens de
dire à l'instant d'ailleurs l'illus
puisque à somme de filière nous disent
dans un premier temps si on veut être
efficace c'est la première génération et
en tout cas après il y aura toujours la
problématique de mobilisation de la de
la biomasse voilà comment vous voyez
cette deuxième génération et
est-ce que vous pensez qu'à un moment
donné quand on ira vers les fioules il y
a un sujet de de transition si j'ose
dire
si la première génération était
fragilisée
est-ce que il y a une possibilité
justement pour le monde agricole de
rester
dans dans cette logique là et de passer
la première génération à la deuxième
génération voir wifioul de continuer à
de continuer à contribuer voilà un peu
les premières questions que je vais vous
poser sachant que mes collègues pourront
s'exprimer ils sont nombreux
comme ça
d'abord merci de vos mots j'entendais le
vice-président dire c'est les bonnes
intentions une question de moyens alors
je vais vous dire il arrive parfois
qu'il y a une question de moyens
mais en fait c'est pas seulement pour le
coup je pense que sur première et
deuxième je reviendrai après sur
deuxième la question c'est pas seulement
des moyens alors il y a besoin mais
quand vous écoutez en particulier les
opérateurs
là les opérateurs aviation qui sont
assez attendent en attente de ces de ces
biocarburants
c'est pas la question de leur moyen pour
le faire c'est la question pour plutôt
des moyens de production qui permettront
de les atteindre vous voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose que le besoin des carbonation est
tel que chacun va faire la part de la
prise en charge me semble-t-il de ces de
cette charge supplémentaire qui est
celle de la décarbonation en revanche
nous il faut qu'on se donne les moyens
de pouvoir répondre à la demande alors
c'est parfois des moyens sans jouer sur
les mots je lui vice-président mais
c'est pas seulement des moyens c'est des
questions d'organisation c'est des
questions de structuration de filière
c'est des questions de bouclage de base
c'est plutôt là qu'on risque de buter
sur le sujet deuxième élément de réponse
pour répondre à Vincent capo canelas
à votre rapporteur
aujourd'hui on est en train de faire la
stratégie et de regarder donc là je vais
voir dans la journée en espagnol unacher
pour parler ces questions là parce que
il y a un sujet qui doit nous mettre en
alerte c'est que beaucoup de monde
s'intéressent à la biomasse agricole
on pourrait dire c'est bon signe
et d'ailleurs c'est bon signe
en revanche je veux qu'on puisse avoir
sur quel usage on va aller prioriser
parce qu'après sinon je vois bien qu'il
y a des opérateurs
qui vont entre
essayer de
faire mettre en oeuvre une concurrence
d'abord il faut que ça soit sous la
maîtrise du monde agricole et du monde
de Laval dépendant du monde agricole et
deuxième élément il faut qu'on ait un
dialogue solide avec ceux qui vont faire
appel à la biomasse pour leur dire ça on
sait faire ça on sait pas faire sans
priorise je vois bien les appels et les
besoins sur l'aviation il y a des tas
d'autres besoins qui sont les
l'aviation c'est quand même au fond sa
voie principale pour essayer de lancer
que l'électrique n'est pas une voie
compte tenu de la charge que ça
représente et donc eux ils vont être
très très friand donc eux ils rentreront
dans la filière simplement j'ai une
petite on a besoin de voir dans ce
bouclage biomasse si tout ça ça coche
bien toutes les cases
de la possibilité de production de
biomasse qu'on a sur le sol français
aujourd'hui il me semble que ça c'est un
élément important sur la question du 2G
il y a des deuxième génération
d'ailleurs je rejoins partie la vie qui
avait été formée je crois par Patrick
pouyanet sur le sur le sujet de la
biomasse évidemment on a un changement
d'échelle je l'ai dit d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure qui est nécessaire compte tenu
du des enjeux qui sont ceux de la
de la de la neutralité carbone en 2050
moi je pense que le sujet principal
c'est
à la fois la massification et la
structuration d'une filière et quels
sont les outils pour le faire et ça je
saurais pas trop vous répondre pour voir
comment on le pousse en tant que tel sur
ce volet là deuxième élément on a besoin
de regarder quels sont les limites de
production de masse agricole et
forestière moi je pense que sur ces 2e
génération ça peut être ça à la limite
c'est il faut qu'on puisse documenter un
peu mieux et on a besoin d'avoir des
éléments qui documentent un peu mieux ce
qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui ce qu'on
pourra faire demain sous dérèglement
climatique je vous rappelle que le la
forêt française stocke aujourd'hui deux
fois moins de carbone qu'elles n'ont
stockée il y a seulement 15 ans
pourquoi parce qu'elle croit moins et
elle dépérit donc la production de bruit
en masse annuel par la forêt française
est plutôt en diminution c'est un autre
exemple mais c'est plus juste pour dire
la mesure des sujets qu'on a devant nous
et donc
retrouvez la capacité de stockage
carbone de la forêt en forêt et demandez
à la forêt par ailleurs de faire ou du
biocarburant ou pour certains ou du
matériau et tout ça et pour moi vertu
je remets pas du tout ça en cause vous
voyez bien il va falloir qu'on regarde
si ça marche vous voyez ce que je dirais
ça c'est à mon avis la recherche la
science qui nous dira un peu ce qu'on
peut faire ce qu'on sait faire ça
nécessite aussi je dis si je retire mon
fil de Forestier ça nécessite aussi
qu'on assume une politique active de
production
absolue c'est la décarbonation
et donc si on veut donner à la
production de biomasse
pour le coup forestière mais je trouve
que l'exemple est pas mauvais en termes
d'illustration
on veut lui faire faire toutes les
fonctions à la fois on arrivera pas
produire de la biomasse or pour que la
forêt répondre aux autres fonctions on a
besoin évidemment
qu'elle puisse limiter le réchauffement
ou le dérèglement climatique appelons-le
comme on veut voilà juste pour dire ces
éléments donc c'est plutôt ça la
contrainte sur 2G deuxième génération
qui est une contrainte de est-ce qu'on
peut et donc de bouclage biomasse qu'on
est en train de réaliser qu'il sera mis
au débat du Parlement dans les dans les
semaines et dans les mois qui viennent
parce que c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on crée
des billies
prenez pas le Savary sénateur de la
Marne oui merci Monsieur le Ministre
merci
pour ces propos moi j'en partage un
grand nombre notamment d'entendre le
discours de la forêt ça fait plaisir
parce que je trouve qu'on en parle pas
suffisamment alors que c'est
effectivement une richesse
extraordinaire non je voulais avoir
quelques questions parce que quand on
travaille sur tout ça on s'aperçoit que
à l'avenir si on parle d'hydrogène ou
autre il va falloir beaucoup
d'électricité beaucoup d'eau beaucoup de
biomasse beaucoup de biomasse également
donc c'est bien de pas mettre tous ses
œufs dans le même panier me semble-t-il
et il y a vraiment un rôle d'ici 2050 à
jouer autour de la biomasse je voulais
savoir un peu votre position parce que
deux points 1 on nous dit que moi j'ai
cru comprendre en tout cas je comprends
peut-être pas tout non plus mais que les
carburantes de deuxième génération
autant on savait au sale pilote ferme et
de passer du pilote à
l'industrialisation c'était déjà
particulièrement compliqué en première
journée on a su faire très bien donc
sachant utiliser déjà ce qui marche
parce que la deuxième génération il y en
a plein plein quand même enfin un nombre
d'interlocuteurs importants qui nous dit
non on sait pas trop passer au stade
d'industrialisation deuxième point
également je voulais savoir ce que vous
pensiez de la thermolyse par
pyrogazéification par rapport à
l'électrolyse pour fabriquer de
l'électricité pour l'hydrogène qui avait
l'intérêt qui avait l'intérêt d'utiliser
un peu moins d'électricité puisque
l'électrolyse utilise beaucoup deux
bouts d'électricité la thermodyse arrive
par des procédés qu'on connaît bien
maintenant qui sont au vieux il a bien
anciens peut-être d'utiliser à la fois
de l'électricité mais en moindre
quantité mais également de la biomasse
donc là aussi c'est une stratégie qui
est divers et je pense que il faut me
semble-t-il travailler sur toutes ces
pistes pas aller pas aller juste sur une
seule piste en ce qui concerne cette
hydrogène et puis d'autre part est
ressorti des des auditions un fait
important c'est que beaucoup également
de nos auditeurs nous ont dit aux
États-Unis ça faire c'est l'IRA ils ont
dit voilà il faut arriver à la
décarbonation on vous donne les moyens
débrouillez-vous ce qu'on veut c'est
arrivé à zéro aux missions en 2050 en
France en Europe on a plutôt tendance à
dire vous voyez l'automobile électrifié
l'automobile on sait que ça va être
quand même pas tout à fait comme ça que
ça va se passer
utilisez telle méthode est-ce que
maintenant vous êtes sur une stratégie
plutôt à définir globalement faire
confiance aux acteurs en disant allez
vers cette voie là on a vu que les
acteurs étaient mobilisés le ferroviaire
il est mobilisé les aériens hier ils
sont dans un plan ils ont déposés quand
même leur plan de filière d'ici 2050
c'est bien structuré bien réfléchi etc
donc est-ce que en France on est dans
une stratégie à faire confiance aux
opérateurs pour qu'ils aient dans cette
direction là et puis sur la forêt
attention effectivement aux mesures
écologiques on voit notamment pour les
débardeurs qui peuvent pas intervenir et
certains moments etc faut concilier ces
mesures écologiques faut concilier le
plus carbone faut concilier la
fabrication de biomasse donc faut tout
le monde que tout le monde mette mais
les gouttes d'huile et au bon endroit
plutôt que les grains de sable et est-ce
que vous pensez y arriver dans ce
domaine là
ce ministre
une précision mais je pense que l'a
peut-être en tête nous avons reçu
notamment l'entreprise apnaire c'est ce
à quoi fait allusion que les chroniques
Savary qui a actuellement une démarche
pilote sur la thermolyse et non
l'électrolyse pour produire de
l'hydrogène et donc potentiellement
aussi produire des fiouls à partir de ça
et qui a priori avec un procédé qui
paraît extrêmement intéressant et qui
serait moins coûteux ça montre bien
aussi qu'on est dans un domaine la voie
de la recherche peut encore nous
permettre
des avancées technologiques et que on
n'est pas enfermé dans des dispositifs
techniques et encore aujourd'hui voilà
je voulais juste décrypter ça parce que
il y a en tout cas un procédé que nous
vous regardons avec la mission et dont
nous savons que le gouvernement est en
train de regarder si oui ou non ça peut
rentrer dans la dans les plans de la
filière hydrogène pour que on soit
capable d'industrialiser
sur la nécessité de diversifier sur ces
sujets là les sources de production
il me semble que dans ce sujet là tant
qu'on est encore dans ces phases on
essaie d'expérimenter trouver des
solutions techniques etc il me semble
que toutes les hypothèses doivent être
posées sur la table y compris celles qui
consomment un peu moins d'eau etc parce
que je pense que c'est quand même
l'erreur tragique ça serait de
s'enfermer dans un seul modèle y compris
dans la production d'hydrogène après sur
le reste techniquement je je prétends
pas à connaître bien des choses mais il
me semble que c'est un élément important
deuxièmement sur la question
deuxième génération oui vous avez raison
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit d'ailleurs
on est encore en phase
d'expérimentation c'est faire un petit
échelle on sait pas industrialisé pour
des raisons de nature diverses c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il faut pousser la
recherche dans le domaine et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut pas en rabattre sur la
première génération
parce que
faut toujours se méfier quand il y a une
rupture technologique de ceux qui sont
dans la première technologie qui
qui trouve que la première était bien et
que le changement de notre deuxième est
bon mais la vérité c'est qu'on bute sur
des impacts techniques sur ces que vous
connaissez aussi enfin
qui viennent produire des contraintes
économiques une deuxième contrainte
c'est qu'à un moment un première
génération deuxième génération pour
aller chercher la même biomasse
je pense sous culture intermédiaire dans
certains cas donc il y aura aussi dans
notre bouclage à penser le système qu'on
soit sûr que on continue à avoir notre
première génération qu'on a une deuxième
génération et que ça se tient en termes
de bouclage biomasse ça me permet de
dire une troisième chose la biomasse
c'est quoi c'est de la photosynthèse
c'est de l'eau
et c'est la capacité à produire donc
c'est aussi les engrais c'est aussi les
produits phytosanitaires dans certains
cas etc faut pas la biomasse c'est ça
c'est factuellement c'est ça c'est pas
la photosynthèse elle est pas elle est
pas sans facteur de production à
l'intérieur enfin si on veut le faire
dans une dans une échelle qui soit celle
auquel qui permet de répondre à nos
besoins je dis au passage que je veux
quand même jamais oublier cette petite
c'est un peu c'est un peu de cycle quoi
mais c'est ce que j'essaie de rappeler
de temps en temps comme vous le savez si
jamais mauvais de le faire
troisième élément de réponse sur
je dis au passage sur les questions
forestière oui ça va être tout l'enjeu
moi je vois beaucoup d'appels de
biomasse forêt
je suis harcelé de gens qui veulent
faire du bois matériaux qui veulent
faire du bois énergie qui va le faire du
biocarburant qui veulent faire du
stockage
carbone en forêt qui veulent préserver
la biodiversité qui veulent que puisse
avoir des activités récréatives il va
falloir qu'on priorise
or la priorisation pour moi c'est quand
même la contribution la stratégie
carbone elle est basée sur réduction
pour ce qu'on peut réduire et réduction
à zéro automobile etc et deux sur une
stratégie qui est basée sur agriculture
et forêt comme puits de carbone donc il
va falloir qu'on les conforte ces
secteurs dans la fonction première qui
doit être la leur qui est une fonction
depuis le carbone parce que si on
n'arrive pas à réguler cette question
climatique à 5 degrés c'est pas la peine
de s'énerver sur la biodiversité
donc le mieux c'est qu'on soit pas à 5
degrés et le mieux pour pas être à 5
degrés c'est qu'on arrive à produire de
la biomasse
pour essayer de stocker ce qu'on peut
stocker au-delà des de la réduction de
la consommation de l'énergie fossile
mais c'est ces deux doubles combinaisons
me semble-t-il importante par ailleurs
on essaie de développer je reviens sur
2G deuxième génération pardon
un certain nombre de projets alors c'est
l'outil principal c'est France
demi-temps la philosophie de France 2030
c'est plutôt une philosophie de faire
confiance aux acteurs par mécanisme
d'appel à projet en regardant comment
ils peuvent se structurer pour essayer
de trouver des solutions donc il me
semble qu'on a une philosophie je sais
pas si c'est ce que vous voulez dire
donc je veux pas travailler votre pensée
la philosophie peut pas être simplement
une philosophie de la réglementation et
de la contrainte la philosophie c'est
une philosophie c'est ce que vous
décrivez peut-être dans la philosophie
américaine d'abord ce n'est pas qu'une
fille enfin notre affaire ne marche que
si elle est européenne sur ces filières
là hydrogène il me semble que c'est une
affaire européenne et donc on a besoin
au niveau de la Commission de convaincre
de l'idée que la question c'est pas de
dire on interdit ça à horizon 2030 c'est
comment on dit aux acteurs voilà les
horizons
neutralité carbone jusqu'au fond le
président Biden si je comprends bien ce
qu'il a dit il a dit 2050 l'objectif
c'est neutralité carbone et maintenant
vous donne les moyens pour atteindre ces
et c'est plutôt ce qu'on a au travers de
France 2030 la vérité la stratégie
française est plutôt celle-là mais il
faut qu'elle soit partagée aux Européens
au niveau européen c'est le sens de ce
cadeau d'ailleurs le président de la
République qui lui a été évidemment
reproché comme souvent qui était de dire
neutralité 2050 par la peine de rajouter
des incrémentations et de dire on refait
de la norme et on rajoute de la norme à
la norme on finit ce qu'on a comme trend
de mesure qui sont liées à cet objectif
là et après il faut que les acteurs s'y
engagent parce que sinon si on
déstabilise la norme en permanence
pour des filières on voit bien la
filière première génération de carburant
il a fallu quand même un peu stabiliser
des dispositifs ce qui n'étaient pas
toujours très simple pour que une
filière se constitue une filière
industrielle elle peut pas se constituer
en trois ans et elle peut pas se
constituer durablement en moins de 10 ou
15 ou 20 ans et donc c'est ça qu'on a
besoin de donner comme perspective aux
acteurs pour répondre à votre question
sur laquelle est la stratégie donc c'est
plutôt une stratégie de faire confiance
aux acteurs dans le cadre qu'on connaît
réduction à 2030 neutralité à 2050
il est Vilaine
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre on n'est pas toujours d'accord
mais ce que vous exposez ce matin
j'adhère pratiquement en totalité
effectivement la première chose c'est
d'avoir
une je dois me rassurer ou m'inquiéter
ça va ça va se dégrader mais pour le
début le début est bon et non mais
effectivement on entend tous les
opérateurs tous les acteurs nous dit ben
voilà nous on pense pouvoir faire ceci
avec la biomasse il faut absolument
avoir une estimation claire et précise
de nos gisements notre potentialité en
France j'ai entendu des chiffres au
niveau mondial on dit que il y a un
milliard un milliard de tonnes de
céréales de produits au niveau mondial
et qu'il en faudrait 300 millions pour
le transport aérien et 300 millions pour
le maritime donc je pense qu'il faut
qu'on ait vraiment des ordres de
grandeur de savoir exactement ce qu'il
faut peut-être que ces chiffres sont pas
fiables à 100% mais
il va falloir passer du rêve à la
réalité c'est-à-dire effectivement la
biomasse il y a une ruée sur la biomasse
mais cette biomasse elle est pas infinie
non plus comme beaucoup de choses donc
vraiment regarder ce dont ce dont on
dispose et sans doute derrière une vraie
planification parce que je veux bien
faire confiance aux opérateurs mais les
opérateurs ils ont tendance à chacun à
travailler dans leur couloirs et ne pas
voir les impacts sur le reste et ça va
être les impacts dans le domaine de
l'énergie mais également sur l'élevage
sur sur toutes les autres filières
agricoles donc il faut regarder ça de
très près et très clairement la solution
sera dans un mix également parce que
même par rapport à la biomasse parfois
du photovoltaïque a un bien meilleur
rendement très clairement que que la
biomasse donc il faut regarder tout cela
je reviendrai sur le sujet quand même
qu'on a exploré à fond avec avec Pierre
Kuiper de la méthanisation je voudrais
vous entendre sur
ce que l'on fait des chaudières à gaz
dans l'avenir est-ce que d'un coup on se
met à toutes et tout électrique comme
c'est en train de se mettre en place ce
qui va poser des gros problèmes de
pointe dans la construction d'énergie
donc je pense que là on est en train de
s'embarquer dans quelque chose qui n'est
pas
qui va pas tenir très clairement puisque
dans les 10 à 15 ans à venir on aura des
problèmes de fournitures d'électricité
donc il faut être très vigilant et je
pense que les chaudière à gaz ont encore
de l'avenir
que dire de plus donc on regarde aussi
le transport aérien effectivement vous
avez parlé de prioriser sans doute que
c'est dans le transport aérien qu'on va
voir le plus besoin de remplacer les
énergies fossiles sachant que l'isier
tout de suite le rendement c'est 50 à
60% d'économie de enfin de moins de gaz
à effet de serre donc c'est pas non plus
la panacée on divise par deux ce qui est
bien mais pas suffisant on en tiendrait
la même chose
avec une division par deux du nombre de
vols donc il y a un moment je vous
entends et c'est là que mon vous n'y
êtes pas encore mais je pense que vous
allez venir on a dit que la fin de
l'abondance la fin de l'abondance ça va
être la décroissance sur de nombreux
secteurs très clairement
vous posez plusieurs questions
que vous posez c'est la question du mix
énergétique et donc c'est pas tout
électrique on a le travaux que vous
menez c'est aussi ça que je pense ça
viendra été j'imagine
ça nécessite qu'on est un mix et ça
nécessite qu'on ait de la planification
j'y viens sur la question de vos
chiffres je
parce que c'est compliqué à une partie
de l'énergie qu'on produit en première
génération c'est pas forcément
directement enfin bref vous savez comme
moi donc
alors c'est pas ce que j'ai entendu dans
vos propos donc je veux pas travailler à
vos propos pour le coup et même si on a
souvent des désaccords mais il faut bien
qu'on commence à lancer des filières
industrielles
oui au fur et à mesure on va découvrir
qu'on a et d'ailleurs on l'a fait sur
première génération plutôt bien c'est à
dire qu'on a puissamment fait en sorte
que ces filières puissent s'organiser
dans les territoires qui étaient
consacrés à ça et après on a mis les en
place les mécanismes de régulation deux
dans la conflictualité des usagers et
pas encore des usages mais des usagers
ce qui est le début de la conflictualité
des le rôle de l'État la puissance
publique c'est de mettre ces gens autour
de la table et leur dire voilà la
puissance disponible
biomasse puissance enfin bref
rappelons-le comme on veut puis voilà
comment on va prioriser
sinon on n'y arrive pas on voit bien
transport aérien va être demandeur
beaucoup de biocarburant de cette nature
de nature agricole bon
ligneuse aussi un peu plus ligneuse
aussi mais enfin bon alors là je diverge
avec vous c'est
on rappelle quand même de tête ces 3,6%
des émissions totales de gaz à effet de
serre
l'aviation civile si on réduit une
moitié ça ferait donc 1,8 % des
émissions totales de gaz à effet de
serre des chiffres en dessous vous avez
même des chiffres en dessous on a plutôt
entendu deux et demi 3 enfin 2,5
si on arrive à un 5 vous voyez il y a un
moment il va falloir qu'on se dise la
neutralité carbone c'est des endroits où
on stock on fait du puits de carbone
c'est la forêt les prairies etc et puis
qu'on accepte qu'il y a des activités on
peut pas être à la neutralité absolue en
tout cas pas dans le pas de temps qu'on
se réclame et donc on peut pas dire à la
fois on essaie de structurer une filière
industrielle et dire en même temps on
lui propose la des la décroissance parce
que si vous dites on réduit par moitié
les vols c'est par moitié les avions et
c'est par moitié la filière parce que
pardon c'est un peu arithmétique mon
affaire mais à la fin ça se finit comme
ça lorsqu'on essaie plutôt c'est d'avoir
une trajectoire qui soit solide d'un
point de vue carbone pour être bien à la
neutralité carbone mais
s'il suffisait de le dire ça serait déjà
compliqué mais s'il faut après il faut
le faire parce que je veux dire dans un
pays comme le nôtre l'aéronautique c'est
un élément important et donc la
stratégie alors attendez la stratégie
qui est la nôtre c'est plutôt une
stratégie de de carburant qui viennent
contribuer à la décarbonation la plus
rapide possible de les de l'énergie de
l'aéronautique je rappelle d'ailleurs
que l'aéronautique je crois en 15 10 ou
15 ans ils ont déjà réduit de moitié
donc réduire de deux fois de moitié
ouais donc c'est pour ça que je dis deux
fois c'est compliqué la première fois le
premier pas est le deuxième pas quand
vous allez les voir ils vous disent
quand même pour un motoriste en 20 ans
de réduire de deux fois 50%
c'est solide mais après il faut qu'il y
ait des filières industriels parce que
c'est il faut choisir après vous êtes
sur une autre option que celle que je
défends mais si l'option c'est de dire
on réduit il n'y aura pas de filière
industrielle si vous dites au fond la
perspective c'est la réduction de
l'aviation moi je crois je crois pas ça
veut pas dire que quand on a d'autres
usages et qu'on peut prendre le train
pour pas le train d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'on a fait au niveau national mais je
reviens à ma question de la priorisation
pardon d'être un peu long monsieur le
vice-président et monsieur le rapporteur
oui on a besoin à la fin et c'est le
travail qu'on va faire dans les semaines
et les mois qui viennent c'est de faire
un bouclage pour dire voilà les usages
voilà les priorités voilà comment on va
faire
parce que sinon je vois bien sur la
filière forêt par exemple les
bois énergie première intention si je
peux dire première génération au
deuxième génération si on peut appeler
ça comme ça c'est-à-dire qu'aux produits
d'exploitation ou pas on voit bien qu'il
peut y avoir entre les opérateurs des
appels de biomasse qui vont un moment
rentrer en concurrence alors en même
temps faut se dire une chose
c'est que c'est de la biomasse il y a 5
ou 10 ou 15 ans qui était pas du tout
valorisé c'est-à-dire qu'on disait c'est
un déchet je vous le prends et il y en a
encore donc il faut oui non mais c'était
quand même c'est comme ça que ça se
passait ça pouvait se passer aussi comme
ça dans d'autres secteurs donc on a
besoin de montrer que parce qu'il y a du
potentiel de production d'énergie ça a
de la valeur et c'est pas si mal que ça
que quand on redonne de la valeur à ce
carbone durable à cette énergie durable
et donc c'est la conflictualité d'usage
au démarrage elle peut aussi stabiliser
des filières pourquoi on a lu longtemps
pas de vrais filières bois énergie c'est
parce qu'il y avait
comment dirais-je Le Forestier n'était
pas n'était pas rémunéré pour ça
voilà c'est pas forcément mauvais signe
qu'il y a de la conflictualité d'usage
seul le message je voulais aussi
rajouter le ministre vous gardez plus
longtemps parce que on a pas mal de
questions donc Lucien Stanzione
et je promets de faire plus court du
Vaucluse
oui monsieur le ministre mais mes deux
collègues ont abordé la question mais
sur la question de la stratégie alors on
partage pas tous les mêmes points de vue
mais
ce que ce que l'on sent au fur et à
mesure des auditions c'est
qu'effectivement il y a pas de
ligne directrice quoi alors mon collègue
Savary dit il faut qu'on laisse la
l'initiative aux opérateurs de terrain
mais en même temps vous répondez il
faudrait avoir une stratégie européenne
sur cette question là bon sur la
question de comment voilà la seule chose
c'est que au niveau de notre
gouvernement on n'entend pas bien dans
les différentes filières là il y a des
solutions
électricité pour l'automobile
la biomasse pour d'autres domaines bon
mais est-ce que vous pensez qu'à un
moment donné dans le cas européen mais
aussi dans le camp national on aura une
stratégie globale qui qui donne une
ligne à suivre la deuxième chose c'est
sur la question de la biomasse
départements du Vaucluse que vous
connaissez bien d'ailleurs
bien le débat il est il est quand même
il est quand même particulier sur sur la
fonction de l'agriculture dans le
domaine alors autant dans le Nord les
grands producteurs
betteraves et autres pour eux c'est à
peu près clair tandis que dans le sud ou
l'agriculture du nature le débat de
savoir si on doit produire la biomasse
dans le cadre agricole ou pas c'est
toujours pas arrêté quoi donc on sent
qu'il y a des tiraillements sur ces
questions là le troisième point c'est
c'est sur la question de l'utilisation
de des biocarburants on a on a reçu
les opérateurs de
aériens eux disent nous on est prêt à à
mettre dans nos carburants jusqu'à 50%
de biocarburant
et alors qu'aujourd'hui ils en mettent 1
à 2 1 2% et que la règle serait autour
de 7 je crois une chose comme ça
aujourd'hui il y a clémentins
d'incorporation qui sont très faibles et
qui vont monter à 6% progressivement
mais ils peuvent monter à 50 sans
problème de certification voilà et alors
qu'en définitive il y a un problème de
production de
que là-dessus il n'y a pas de réponse
quoi et puis le dernier point je
souhaitais avoir votre avis sur sur le
fait que on a reçu les pétroliers
parmi lesquels un grand qui qui semble
dire bon aujourd'hui la recherche dans
ce domaine là c'est pas tout à fait une
priorité absolue il y a encore du
pétrole bon on continue dans le pétrole
puis on verra plus tard quoi et c'est un
acteur principal quand même de la
question quoi donc qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça et comment on peut régler
cette affaire
j'ai rapidement le pétrolier défend le
pétrole
est-ce qu'il y a une nouveauté
est-ce qu'il y a une nouveauté ah oui
peut-être oui pardon on avait dit
la biomasse des biocarburant
s des installations quelle prise en
compte au niveau du zan alors quel
volume de surface prise en compte plutôt
optimiste ou plutôt restrictive pour ces
installations et dans quel bloc de
répartition
les prévoyez-vous merci des
installations de production biomasse ou
des surfaces agricoles consacrées
pour transformer de la biomasse
de l'Hérault et Bernard but peut-être
non merci merci monsieur le président
moi je voudrais parler d'une filière un
particulier qui me semble-t-il serait
prometteuse pour donc produire du
biocarburant même si il y a quand même
un corps donc des innovations à faire
notamment pour la maîtrise des coûts
mais par rapport aussi à une cohérence
des politiques que vous engagez c'est la
filière viticole aujourd'hui il y a eu
une expérience menée par totale énergie
dans une course automobile réputée les
24 Heures du Mans ou les carburants dans
les voitures étaient
issues donc de la distillation des
résidus Marc Élie des vins voilà
et je trouve donc que cette expérience
était très intéressante et
vous avez un début d'année et je vous en
remercie d'ailleurs par rapport à une
crise viticole importante notamment dans
le Bordelais
débloquer donc une enveloppe pour la
distillation donc de plus de 1 million
d'hectolitre de vin pourquoi ne pas
conditionner cette aide que vous avez
apporté à la condition donc de produire
de l'éthanol et du bioéthanol voilà
parce que je trouve que ça serait
cohérent dans
les dans d'une situation de crise que
vous avez
réglé deuxième question par rapport donc
et on l'a évoqué hier dans le groupe
viniévin sur le fort degré aujourd'hui
du
réchauffement climatique de nos vins
et la volonté d'un certain viticulteur
de désalcoolisés leur production ça
existe
mais moi j'en connais un qui m'a
interrogé là-dessus et qui a d'énormes
difficultés dans l'alcool qui récupère
pour le réintroduire dans leur les
engins viticoles les difficultés
administratives qu'il y a derrière tout
ça donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
éclairer un petit peu sur ces sujets
merci monsieur le ministre
alors je reviens donc sur la question
que vous évoquez
que les gens qui travaillent dans le
pétrole défend le pétrole n'est pas une
totale découverte son mauvais jeu de
mots
après ils doivent s'inscrire dans la
trajectoire qu'on a fixé qui est une
soirée d'histoire de neutralité carbone
de 2050 donc ça s'applique à eux ça
s'applique à eux comme à tout le monde
et à la vérité si vous regardez les
grands ensembles continentaux l'Europe
les États-Unis etc ils sont qui sont
quand même les plus gros consommateurs
d'énergie fossiles
après qui puisse rester quelques
activités où il y aura encore besoin
d'énergie difficile ça rend d'autant
plus rare les énergies fossiles au-delà
de leur des contraintes qu'elles font
peser et des risques qu'elles font peser
sur le climat certes mais enfin la
vérité c'est que la trajectoire c'est la
diminution voir la disparition interne
de l'utilisation des énergies fossiles
sauf sujet résiduel sur lequel on aurait
pas encore les solutions techniques
c'est maintenant ce sujet là comme sur
l'autre mais sur les énergies fossiles
on est en train de trouver sur bien des
sujets les solutions techniques c'est
plutôt le bouclage énergétique qui va
être un sujet ce que disait le sénateur
sa varie c'est qu'elle part
d'électricité quelle part de c'est
plutôt ça notre interrogation qu'on doit
porter
technologiquement on voit bien qu'on
peut quand même essayer d'y aller donc
je réponds simplement que ils doivent
être comme les autres parce que c'est
quand même c'est parce qu'on a libéré
des énergies fossiles qu'on est dans
cette situation là alors que ceux qui
produisent des énergies fossiles
je crois pas qu'ils en est pas
conscience je trouverais ennuyeux qu'ils
en aient pas conscience mais tout le
monde a conscience que de toute façon
cette trajectoire là c'est une
trajectoire qui faut tenir sinon on n'y
arrivera pas deuxième élément je sais
pas si c'est ce que vous voulez dire sur
le Vaucluse que je connais un peu
effectivement
c'est pas les mêmes conditions il va
falloir qu'on réfléchisse aussi
territorialement c'est ce que je disais
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure sur la
question de qu'est-ce que va produire
des règlements climatique j'étais comme
vous le savez il y a quelques semaines
oui encore des semaines dans les
Pyrénées Orientales la question dans ces
territoires là quand vous avez 90 mm
d'eau qui est tombé en un an ou 100 mm
d'eau vous allez pas produire beaucoup
de biomasse
donc le sujet principal c'est comment
vous maintenez une activité agricole qui
fait vivre des gens qui répondent à nos
besoins de souveraineté parce que quand
même votre département le Pyrénées
et légumes c'est quand même un endroit
qui est important pour nous nous
nationalement
des discussions que vous avez compris
sur les sujets forestiers à un moment il
faut maintenir une forêt qui permet
d'éviter les incendies de forêt
un tissu agricole forestier qui permet
d'éviter des incendies de forêt je lui
dis au passage
les incendies de l'an dernier c'est 2
millions de tonnes de CO2 qui ont été
dégagés en France je crois que dans le
monde c'est 10 à 15 %. alors c'est
volontaires ou involontaire d'ailleurs
dès le gaz à effet de serré Miss c'est
des incendies de forêts donc la présence
je crois que c'est 10 je vois que le
sénateur seulement doute ce qui lui
arrive parfois quand je parle mais
c'est
il va vérifier je crois que c'est 10
donc c'est pas rien et donc donc on a
besoin de maintenir aussi une activité
agricole dans ses fonctions qui
permettent aussi d'éviter ça mais c'est
une chose de dire ça dans ce territoire
là que de le dire mais dans ces
territoires là il sent qu'il va falloir
plutôt qu'on se dise quelle est
l'activité agricole qui permet qui peut
qui peut être sous contrainte climatique
donc la question de l'accès à l'eau etc
mais qui permet sous contrainte
climatique de maintenir une activité
agricole elle-même stockeuse de carbone
parce que quand vous avez un peu de
prairie quand vous avez un peu
d'arboriculture quand vous avez de la
vigne tout ça ça contribue quand même
dans le cycle à stocker le carbone dans
les sols en particulier donc c'est
plutôt comme ça qu'il va falloir
l'aborder dans des territoires sous ses
contraintes là pendant ce que c'est un
élément important vous disiez on sait
pas s'il y a une stratégie non on est au
moment où là pour la première fois
maintenant on essaie de faire ce qui n'a
jamais été fait alors
pourrait dire vous le faites trop tard
mais on prend les choses aussi où on
essaie de boucler à la fois la capacité
de production de biomasse et des
trajectoires de décarbonation et de
regarder les usages et c'est les travaux
que vous faites là et c'est des travaux
qui vont être mis à votre à votre débat
dans la stratégie nationale bacone dans
ces stratégies là ce qu'on essaie de
faire dans les travaux qu'on mène avec
la première ministre depuis deux mois si
on rajoute les usagers hier soir j'avais
une réunion sur la forêt la semaine
d'avant on avait une ange sur la
question agricole la semaine d'avant une
question sur NRJ et après on va regarder
si tout ça produit notre cohérence donc
ce que je trouve intéressant dans la
démarche qu'on mène actuellement c'est
justement de la mise en cohérence c'est
de pas plus parler un peu en l'air de
faut de la deuxième génération faut de
la première génération
il y a qu'à faire des méthaniseurs enfin
bref maintenant il faut poser regardez
les usages il faut qu'on dise aussi dans
la planification y compris dans les
conflictualités territoriales ça
m'amènera la question zan on voit bien
que il y a un certain nombre de dès lors
qu'on commence à produire de l'énergie
dans un certain nombre de territoires et
au lien
voltaïque méthanisation ou autre et
immédiatement ça se tend sur les
territoires or on peut pas à la fois
dire il faut une trajectoire neutralité
carbone et dire qu'il faut pas ces
énergies là moi je sais pas faire sinon
la vérité c'est que je sais pas faire
donc on a besoin d'avoir de dire on a
besoin de temps le méthaniseur on a
besoin donc de tels biomasse donc de
telles apport on a besoin de temps voilà
c'est comme ça qu'il va falloir qu'on
fasse donc c'est j'entends votre appel à
la cohérence c'est exactement ce qu'on
fait et c'est ça qui vous sera soumis
c'est de dire est-ce qu'on est bien
d'accord sur les sur ce qu'on peut tirer
de biomasse pour ce qui est de la
question que vous me posez aujourd'hui
et qu'est-ce que ça produit comme usage
et les arbitrages qu'il faudra faire
parce qu'il faudra faire des arbitrages
on va pas vendre trois fois la même
biomasse
c'est sinon on se verse là aussi
d'illusion dans le mix énergétique donc
c'est plutôt ça et hier il y a quand
même aussi une stratégie c'est une
stratégie qui doit être portée aussi au
niveau européen là c'est plutôt un
travail à mon avis qui est devant nous
madame la sénatrice vous m'avez
évoqué en fait la question alors là vous
me posez quand même là vous êtes vous la
question c'est de quelle surface on va
avoir besoin en terme
d'artificialisation pour avoir des
unités de production d'énergie donc
sésame oui pardon permettez-moi de
préciser dans le prolongement de ce que
vous venez de dire on va avoir donc vous
disiez on va avoir besoin de déterminer
quel besoin en biomasse en méthaniseur
etc donc dans le prolongement de cela
quel moyen on se donne dans le zan avec
des quotas qui ne seront pas impactés
sur les collectivités
la PPL dite l'état blanc est supposé
fournir un certain nombre d'éléments de
réponses et que on souhaite que ça
prospère
j'ai tout bien compris la question qui
m'était posée
le sénateur creeper c'est à réfléchir à
répondre la vérité sur la question
oui la question qui va se poser qui est
celle qui est de la PPL qui est en train
de cours de navette parlementaire c'est
la question de sur des usages qui sont
des usages d'intérêt général est-ce
qu'on est bien sûr une approche
artificialisation qui n'est pas un
usage d'utilisation particulière il me
semble que la logique c'est plutôt
celle-là je suis d'accord avec vous je
préoccupe pas le débat et je veux pas
présenter le débat sur mon collègue mais
dès lors qu'on se dit on a besoin des
carboner c'est une priorité nationale il
faut qu'on atteint l'objectif neutralité
carbone il me semble que c'est pas
complètement illogique de poser la
question de dire est-ce que cet
artificialisation là
d'ailleurs il faut qu'on regarde
d'ailleurs dans quelle mesure elle est
la prolongation d'un acte de production
agricole parce que c'est une façon de
régler ce problème là mais quand vous
allez faire des grandes usines dès lors
qu'on arrivera industrialiser la
deuxième génération c'est pas
complètement directement là prolongation
une activité mais évidemment que ça fait
partie ça fait partie des
infrastructures d'artificialisation dont
on peut se poser la question comme
d'autres ouvrages c'est un pot national
ou c'est un pot local ça rentre dedans
ou ça sort bien sûr parce que le zéro
artificialisation net pose ce type de
questions mais moi il me semble que dans
la logique globale après est-ce que
quand vous faites
je sais pas quoi est-ce que quand vous
faites des je reprends un sujet qu'on
n'a pas évoqué parce que ça n'a pas lu
aujourd'hui vous faites de l'éolien
c'est considéré comme vous voyez ce que
jusqu'à quelle surface et quel type
d'énergie ça c'est une autre question
qu'il faut se poser il me semble-t-il
dans cette sujet-là et puis quand à la
question viticole
je n'avais pas repéré que les 24 Heures
du Mans
avaient fonctionné comme ça la question
viticole
ben j'ai regardé sur la question de la
conditionnalité enfin je vois bien de
est-ce que il faut d'abord un il faut
qu'on poursuive la recherche et les sur
les usages c'est ça ce que ça veut dire
d'abord parce qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup de gens et donc France 2030
doit être un outil qui permet de dire
j'ai besoin de désalcooliser je fais de
la distillation et vous avez raison on a
plutôt vrai je crois utilement pour la
filière on va atterrir bientôt avec la
Commission européenne ça sera pas trop
tôt un message personnel pas à vous sur
ces questions de distillation mais
qu'après on regarde alors après je veux
pas vous répondre directement sur enfin
là tout de suite ça mérite d'être gardé
sur c'est une forme de conditionnalité
qui est un peu compliqué surtout au
moment où on va on va décider mais je
trouve qu'on dise qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait à la vérité à la vérité c'est ça la
question et pourquoi on la valoriserait
pas dans un processus de décarbonation
mais c'est peut-être continué qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de ça et je pense que le plus
promet de fin pour mettre le plus tu
dois susciter pour moi et pour nous le
plus interrogation c'est
désalcoolisations qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire de ça
en termes d'énergie et il me semble on a
besoin de faire de creuser toutes ces
pistes ça rejoint ce que disait le
sénateur Savary sur comment on a besoin
d'avoir un mix toute solution qui permet
d'aller chercher de la biomasse en
deuxième intention
la biomasse qui produit de l'énergie
parce que c'est ça en fait ce que vous
dites la désalcoolisation c'est de la
biomasse qui produit de l'énergie c'est
au début c'est de la biomasse c'est le
raisin c'est de la biomasse et ça il
faut regarder la conditionnalité je vais
regarder est-ce que c'est peut-être un
peu compliqué à mettre en œuvre
ouais bien sûr ça on sait faire ça on
sait faire
il faut que je sois 58 je commence
on vous remercie déjà de
répondre à toutes nos questions deux
points sur le potentiel de biomasse je
me demande si nous avons les moyens
aujourd'hui je monte objectivé le sujet
de l'estimer est-ce qu'il y a pas une
mesure à prendre et peut-être des choses
à regarder on essaiera faire peut-être
de faire oeuvre de proposition là-dessus
pour objectiver sujet beau après j'ai
quand même noté que vous vous ne dites
priorisez parce que on est toujours
quand même un peu prudent quand on se
dit on va prendre des grandes masses
alors le potentiel d'électricité d'eau
de biomasse et puis avec tout ça on va
on va planifier de manière trop stricte
bon il y a peut-être une façon
effectivement de donner des priorités et
en tout cas j'ai noté aussi que sur la
deuxième génération vous avez bien en
tête qu'il y a un problème pour
l'industrialisé alors là-dessus on a
entendu nous trois choses le coup des
usines
il y a un facteur 3 ou 4 quand même il y
a un vrai sujet sur comment commencer à
industrialiser là-dessus on a donc un
problème de production on n'aura pas de
volume parce que effectivement même le
président de la SNCF voyageurs nous dit
moi sur mes trains la partie qui n'est
pas électrifiée effectivement je veux
j'en voudrais mais j'en ai pas bon qui
est donc il y a un sujet bon et puis on
a un troisième problème qui aime qui est
de prix donc le maturité du marché de
comment on est capable d'avoir de
construire de réguler un marché mature
et avec des clients à la fin parce que
ça va pas être que des fonds publics il
y a quand même un sujet on a vu des
entreprises y compris dans le secteur de
l'hydrogène d'ailleurs qui nous disent
tout ça est bien bon ok les appels à
projet nous aider à faire des filières
etc mais finalement si on a au bout des
clients et un marché mature avec un prix
ça donnera quand même une visibilité à
tout le monde parce qu'on voit bien
aussi que les investisseurs attendent
entre temps voilà donc il y a peut-être
quelques petits sujets sur la deuxième
génération donner un coup d'accélérateur
et de franchir le pas sur les usines
mais surtout de construire un marché
mature et sur le la biomasse voilà de
réfléchir il y a un centre d'organismes
qu'on a qu'on a reçu notamment l'inrae
on se dit il va pouvoir contribuer à
nous aider à objectiver ça avec les
contraintes que vous avez rappelé très
bien sur sur le changement climatique
aussi
c'était la dernière question
pour la prévenir
juste dans le temps imparti d'abord sur
la biomasse vous avez raison c'est et
c'est travail qu'on demande à l'inrae de
je pense qu'on ne pourra faire que des
fourchettes sous telle ou tel type de
contrainte
on sait ce que voit ce que donne le
dérèglement climatique on sait pas enfin
globalement mais on sait pas
territorialement tout à fait ce que ça
va donner on n'est pas certain des
modèles et il faut pas faire que elle a
la science d'ailleurs il vaut mieux
qu'on soit un peu
pas trop arrogant sur ces sujets qui
sont un peu compliqués moi je trouve les
sujets donc on va pouvoir donner des
fourchettes et puis on a des donc ça
c'est un élément il faut continuer à
documenter parce que c'est vrai que tant
qu'on a pas ça c'est compliqué deuxième
élément oui la question est là ça
rejoint la question initiale de Pierre
cuir c'est les usines de G là la
question des moyens c'est une question
d'accompagnement financier dès lors
qu'on aura des processus qui peuvent
être industrialisés parce que là pour le
coup ça fera sortir ou pas les les
usines de terre que de crédibiliser les
choses troisième élément c'est ce que
vous dites c'est la la part du la
contractualisation de la commande privée
au public d'ailleurs pour crédibiliser
une filière c'est ça ce que vous dites
c'est toujours les mêmes sujets moi je
pense que la principale mais d'autres
diront peut-être d'autres choses
d'autres collègues ministres viennent
ici il me semble que le sujet principal
c'est parce que justement on n'arrive
pas vraiment à bien répondre sur les
usages et qu'est-ce qu'on a de
disponible que personne se lance
vraiment vous voyez ce que je veux dire
je pense qu'on a besoin de crédibiliser
c'est pour ça que j'y tiens beaucoup ce
qu'est la biomasse théoriquement
disponible avec des fourchettes qui font
se donner
de précautions positive ou des
précautions négatives dans les deux sens
c'est comme ça qu'on pourra commencer à
dire prioriser alors quand je dis
priorisé ça veut pas dire exclusif mais
quand même se dire on l'a ça biomasse on
peut en mettre mettons des hypothèses
qui permettent de faire ici de
l'aéronautique là du matériel agricole
et à partir de là on fait parce que
le sentiment que donne beaucoup
d'opérateurs quand ils viennent nous
voir c'est qu'en fait ils ne croient pas
qu'à tout ça en biomasse donc non mais
non parce que comme il y a aussi les
usages pour l'énergie je sais pas quoi
il y a les yeux et donc en fait on a
besoin de dire la biomasse qui peut être
appelé produite pour qu'après on
crédibilise des filières qui se
construiraient et c'est à mon avis par
là qu'on résoudra cette équation
bien
oui
on va terminer je voulais simplement
avoir votre avis sur un propos purement
technique et sémantique
nous entendons il est écrit il est dit
que c'était la fin du moteur thermique
pour 2035
or on vient de parler biomasse et on
sait très bien et le Président puyanais
nous l'a rappelé c'est que le moteur
thermique doit continuer d'exister
puisque c'est pas le moteur thermique en
soi qui est qui doit être mis en cause
dans les écrits en tout cas c'est le
carburant qui doit être décarboné dans
ce moteur thermique il y a une erreur
qu'il faut corriger me semble-t-il qu'en
pensez-vous
parce que si on veut mettre de la
biomasse faire bien moteur thermique ça
se fera pas comme ça
il y a un moment faut quand même donner
une trajectoire qui dise que parce que
candidats
attendez ce qu'on assume dans la
trajectoire agricole c'est qu'on peut
pas demander à l'agriculture d'être
neutre en carbone c'est pas possible
parce qu'elle produit de la biomasse
donc de toute façon continue à un peu
émettre de carbone et en particulier le
secteur agricole est un secteur y
compris dans les discussions qu'on aille
en interne ministérielle ou il y a une
trajectoire de réduction mais qui est
moins demandé que sur l'aviation c'est
plutôt neutralité absolue pourquoi parce
que on demande à la culture de nous
nourrir faut jamais quand même l'oublier
au passage et par ailleurs de produire
de l'énergie dont on a besoin
dont on a besoin pour des carboner mais
donc on
peut pas à la fois demander ça et en
même temps dire sur la question des
moteurs thermiques que on essaie pas
quand même de sortir du moteur thermique
parce que même de l'énergie première ou
deuxième génération elle a un tout petit
peu de carbone il renouvelable ouais
mais et donc il me semble qu'il faut
qu'on préserve des usages il y aura
encore des murs thermiques on sait très
bien qu'il y a des bas par exemple
l'avion c'est plutôt du moteur thermique
l'avion ça reste du moteur thermique
enfin j'entends pas autre chose que
personne ne dit qu'on va faire de
l'électrique
[Musique]
bon et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
l'aviation est très demandeuse de
carburant de cette nature on sait très
bien qu'aujourd'hui sur le modèle
agricole on a du mal sur les engins
qu'on a en agriculture en tout cas les
gros engins à faire autre chose que des
thermiques mais réservons ça il n'a pas
résiduelle qu'on ne s'est pas résoudre
aujourd'hui plutôt me semble-t-il que de
dire là on pourrait passer à
l'électrique faire de l'électrique parce
que sinon on ouvre une boîte ou à la fin
on va dire on fait comme avant c'est ça
le risque me semble-t-il
merci monsieur le ministre nous sommes
une minute en avance merci voilà merci à
vous merci merci à vous chers collègues